now the comedian jimmy carr has been
widely criticized for a disparaging joke
about the death of thousands within the
travelling community during the
holocaust he made the comments in his
latest netflix special his dark material
the traveler movement which supports
travellers in the uk have called the
joke truly disturbing
well joining me now is the comedian and
political activist kate smithwaiter kate
good to see you did you watch this
episode
i didn't watch it i know it came out at
christmas and we did talk about it at
the time um but you know there's
hundreds of shows on and to be honest
when you do comedy for a living um the
last thing you want to do is spend your
free time watching yet more comedy so i
so i was unaware and i knew that the
show was was predicated on the idea of
there was going to be a lot of dark
comedy in it but it was only when it
suddenly hit the news yesterday that i
was like oh really i mean you know i i
know jimmy well and i know that he often
you know edges around controversial
subjects and he likes to kind of get a
bit of a gasp you know before a laugh
quite often and and but he in my
experience and when i've worked with him
in the past he's always kind of
you know done the sort of setup where
you're like that's outrageous you can't
say that but then the punchline has
turned it around and you're like oh you
know it's it there's a twist on this you
know
he says murder and it turns out he means
crows um you know this kind of thing
there's a twist that that that takes you
away from the dark uh side of it um so
then of course i went and looked at this
and i mean obviously like i'm sure
everybody um who did the same the joke
is horrible the joke is horrific and
then i was like let's be fair and look
at it in the context because there's
always context to these things and you
know the context is indeed that he's
trying to say outrageous things and
making the point that you know however
offensive the things he says the
audience seem to keep laughing and
laughing and laughing and
you know and it's important that we look
at these things in context but i think
when we look at the context of this i i
don't think that the context justifies
what has been said i think the joke is
is horrible it's it's incredibly
disrespectful to members of the gypsy
roman traveler community and that's a
group of people who are currently um you
know having their way of life absolutely
decimated by the new uh pcsc bill um
there's lots of stuff going on at the
moment that there's people who
experience enormous levels of
discrimination and enormous levels of uh
you know social um
harassment and all kinds of stuff like
this and i think it's
you know i think it's absolutely the
wrong target to use to demonstrate how
offensive you're you know you can make
your jokes and i also think you say you
say you know him and um you've worked
with him do you think he's he's
remorseful for this does he think i got
this wrong
um i haven't i haven't heard from him on
that front um but you know i
like i hope that he'll have a look at it
and go this is the wrong thing to do and
this is this has come across the wrong
way and it's not what i set out to do
and you know i think people should be at
liberty to you know admit their errors
and take the material down take the show
down and um and and edit it or replace
it with something else i think that that
that would make a lot of sense i'd be
delighted if he did that i also i'm kind
of surprised that you know he's a he's a
a talented comedian and an intelligent
man and i think i'm kind of surprised
that he didn't stop himself before this
went to air and go actually do i really
want my name on this kind of thing
because i think kate you said that you
found it offensive yeah i mean it's
clearly it's not we're calling it a joke
it's not a joke is it and it's just it's
just not a joke um
would you consider cancelling netflix if
they don't remove it
um i think that netflix should remove it
um i think that you know he is of course
you know we all have free speech he's
free to say whatever he wants but you're
not free to say whatever you want
without consequences um and netflix has
every right to make choices about what
they do and don't want on their platform
as do indeed all channels including
yourselves in fact there are words i
could say right now and i know you'd
never book me again it's um
the fact is that everybody makes
everybody who produces content for tv
for radio for newspapers for magazines
has a choice over what they do and don't
put on and i think netflix have made the
wrong choice and i think that there will
be a lot of pressure on them and a lot
of people quite reasonably feeling like
you know if they're not going to take
action over things like this they want
to cancel their netflix subscription and
i think that's great in fact it just
ties into the piece you just did about
um iceland stopping whale hunting
because they were saying well people
just don't want to buy whale meat
anymore so commercially it's not viable
well if people don't want to listen to
comedy shows that contain offensive
racist material then the pressure will
be on netflix to take those shows down
because that's you know it i don't think
it always works that you know consumers
can put pressure on companies and
companies do the right thing but
sometimes it does it's working for the
icelandic uh whaling industry we're
closing that down by all not eating
whale and congratulations to the the
residents and visitors to iceland for
doing that and i hope that netflix
identifies that again commercially this
is the wrong decision and morally it's
the wrong decision to leave this up
because it's a really offensive piece of
material and it it has no place in our
modern culture and we should be looking
at what we can do to be more inclusive
of the gypsy roma and traveller
community and especially what we can do
to make sure that the latest piece of
government legislation isn't allowed to
hurt them in the way that it potentially
is about to do